[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition du journal de l
la rédaction voici les titres de cette
édition du 5 janvier 2017
sky one portal spécialisée dans la
réalité virtuelle à l'assaut des états
unis la start up de montigny le
bretonneux est actuellement présente aux
crs de las vegas grand messe annuelle de
la high-tech thierry mandon secrétaire
d'état en charge de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche présents
hier à l'université de versailles saint
quentin un déplacement afin de lancer le
nouvel examen d'entrée pour les avocats
et puis un autre déplacement
gouvernemental celui de najat vallaud
belkacem la ministre de l'éducation et
elle a été elle à clairefontaine pour
promouvoir le football comme outil
éducatif les résidences c'est dorénavant
le nouveau nom du bailleur social
l'opievoy un changement de nom qui
s'accompagne également de changement en
profondeur l'opievoy été dissous le 31
décembre dernier pour être remplacé par
une société anonyme hlm qui reprend donc
la gestion de 30000 logements répartis
sur les yvelines mais aussi sur
l'essonne ce changement doit permettre
de faciliter la gestion au quotidien et
la réalisation des grands projets mais
cela n'entame n'entraînera aucune
augmentation de loyer assurent les
dirigeants
c'est parti pour l'édition 2010 est du
consumer electronic show de las vegas le
ces le cee s1 ça un salon un show dédié
aux technologies du numérique avec 275
start-up la france est la troisième plus
grande délégation présente et dans ses
rangs l'entreprise sky one portal
direction donc las vegas le reportage
est signée nicolas attendri depuis les
yvelines tout de même une start-up
saint-quentinoise ocs 2017 de las vegas
sky one portal est engagé dans le
secteur de la réalité virtuelle pour sa
deuxième participation consumer
electronic show
les attentes sont importantes ils
s'élèvent pour nous c'est vraiment une
occasion de
de tisser des liens avec des grands
industriels de faire connaître notre
savoir-faire dans le meilleur des cas on
avait quelques contres avec duff triel
c'est ce qui est arrivé l'année dernière
donc là on va voir ce que ça va donner
clairement et on a des retombées en
termes de communication c'est une grosse
mise en visibilité de ce prophète
l'idée c'est que le maximum de personnes
puissent tester la solution c'est la
technologie quelle technologie assez
novatrice pour la réalité virtuelle
orienté grand public
deux installations seront accessibles
aux visiteurs du cs avec peut-être des
contrats à la clé créé en 2013 cette
start up est installé à montigny le
bretonneux dans la pépinière
d'entreprises promo paul ollivier le
cran avec emmanuel écart et julien
bassens ont voulu démocratiser les
systèmes de réalité virtuelle pour les
particuliers
là le fait qu'il ya un capteur je vais
pouvoir être actif avec le monde
numérique
c'est dire qu'elle veut pouvoir
sélectionner par exemple ici des jeux
donc là c'est un jeu qu'on a développé
le but étant d'éviter les obstacles et
d'aller dalle d'attraper les ballons
jaunes deux projecteurs pour le mur et
le sol un capteur de mouvement ce
système est aussi utile pour les
entreprises industrielles
oui typiquement font des visites
d'appartements à l'échelle 1 ou alors
font des revenus numériques de leurs
projets pour faire des validations
d'avancement de projets d amende et
validation de jalons justement dans les
revues numérique par rapport à la
conception de nouveaux bâtiments pour ce
système de réalité virtuelle comptait
vingt mille euros destinés aux
particuliers le système skalli atteint
les 5000 euros en 2016
sky one portal compte prix de 30
systèmes déployés dans le monde à
l'occasion du lancement de la réforme de
l'examen d'entrée dans les écoles
d'avocats thierry mandon le secrétaire
d'état en charge de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche a rencontré
hier les étudiants inscrits les
étudiants candidats
l'institut d'études judiciaires lio j ai
qui dépend de l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines le sujet est
signée haussmann vendeurs des et camille
lambert
il était présent hier à l'université
versailles saint quentin pour le
lancement de la réforme d'entrée dans
les écoles d'avocats thierry mandon
secrétaire d'état en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche a pu faire un point devant une
centaine d'étudiants sur cette réforme
qui l'a porté à bras le corps on
constate sur territoire français d des
taux de succès très variable selon les
universités et à cet examen reposer sur
des règles qui finalement faisait que
ceux qui formaient les étudiants étaient
aussi partis à la sélection de ce qui
allait être avocat donc il y avait des
mesures et d'égalité de justice qui
l'imposait et pour résoudre cette
inégalité de justice thierry mandon a
décidé d'uniformiser l'examen d'entrée
dans les écoles d'avocats
une mesure qui permet d'avoir un
concours d'entrée homogène pour tous les
étudiants
cette réforme répond à un besoin
d'égalité et s'inscrit évidemment dans
une dynamique républicaine d'accès égal
au mieux égale à tous les étudiants à la
profession d'avocat
je crois qu'un certain nombre de nos
collègues enseignants chercheurs voire
même à responsabilités ont beaucoup plus
vrai dans cette direction ce nouvel
examen unique avec le même sujet pour
tous aura lieu pour la première fois en
septembre 2010 est un autre déplacement
ministériel dans l'actualité locale
najat vallaud-belkacem la ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui s'est rendu
hier à clairefontaine l'antre du
football français pour assister à une
session de formation des enseignants une
formation et qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'un partenariat entre différents
acteurs pour favoriser la pratique du
football justement à l'école les
précisions sont signées nicolas
kirillovitch sur des images de nos
confrères dix villes est une première
c'est un paradoxe que les acteurs du
football français constatent depuis des
années le ballon rond est le sport le
plus pratiqué enfonce mais il n'est
presque jamais enseigné à l'école
préjugés mauvaise image polémique pour
inverser la tendance l'éducation
nationale et les instances du football
on décide de faire la pédagogie du sport
pratiqué par plus de deux millions de
personnes
chacun de nous se posent les mêmes
questions à l'égard de foot c'est à dire
que à la fois on voit bien qu'il ya une
appétence évidente des jeunes pour le
football et en même temps le football
que aussi souffrir d'une certaine
réputation voit le foot professionnel
plus que parfois les richesses d'une
foot amateur 200 enseignants du premier
degré et professeur de sport suivi une
formation à clairefontaine un
investissement important pour la
fédération française de football on
avait besoin de de réaffirmer les
valeurs du football aussi à l'école et
c'est pour ça que noël le graet a fait
le choix avec son équipe et avec
l'ensemble des salariés et surtout notre
direction technique nationale 2 mais des
moyens humains parce que des cadres
techniques vont accompagner les
enseignants vont voilà faire la
promotion de ce dispositif dont je vous
ai parlé m'ont euro 2016 faut beau les
princesses donc oui bien sûr c'est un
coup très très conséquents mais c'était
une volonté politique et on s'en réjouit
le football espère rapidement se créer
une place dans l'enseignement sportif à
l'école objectif 2019 et l'organisation
par la france de la coupe du monde
féminine de football
nous parlons de sport encore avec un
exploit inédit qui s'est déroulé sur la
piste du vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous en avions
déjà parlé dans notre édition d'hier
mercredi robert marchand 105 ans a
réussi un nouveau record de l'heure il a
réalisé devant plus de 1000 spectateurs
et la plupart étaient en plus ses amis à
22 km et 547 m retour sur une
performance inédite un nouveau record
avec michael et demi d'euros les images
sont signés patrick jacques de dixmude
il a repoussé les limites de son sport
robert marchand 105 ans de guerre
mondiale et cesse président à son actif
a établi un nouveau record de l'heure
dans une catégorie d'âge créé
spécialement pour lui le centenaire a
réalisé ce mercredi 4 janvier 22 km 547
m une performance inédite
je ressens un peu d'émotion d'avoir tout
ça pour quoi comment voulez-vous et at
il dit
comme pour le soutenir tout au long de
son défi une centaine de supporteurs de
son club de l'ardéchoise a fait le
déplacement
700 kilomètres en allemand parti matin
6h30 on a passé une journée formidable
c'est notre mascotte au salaire des
choses notre mascotte supermarché c'est
robert marchand juif père marchand
sévèrement au total plus de 80
journalistes et 1000 spectateurs ont
garni les tribunes du vélodrome
parmi eux marcel le quéré spécialistes
de la discipline qui pourrait s'attaquer
au record de robert marchand dans
quelques années j'ai encore 35 ans à
tenir pour arriver à son niveau c'est
exceptionnel ce qu'il fait déjà nous à
70 ans déjà très difficile à jonage
c'est merveilleux ça nouvel espoir de
tenir encore plusieurs années
une journée parfaite pour robert
marchand mais le centenaire qui a tourné
à 35 secondes au tour à la fin de son
exposé ne se satisfait pas pleinement de
sa performance
j'ai pas vu mais les bienvenus une
simple erreur de jeunesse robert
marchand pourrait tenter de corriger ce
détail à l'occasion d'un nouveau record
dans deux ans
apparemment il lui en reste sous la
les félicitations une nouvelle fois à
lui pour cet exploit à peine les fêtes
terminées la galette des rois s'impose
dans les boulangeries une tradition
toujours bien ancrée dans les familles
nous sommes allés suivre la préparation
de ces fameuses galettes à voisins le
bretonneux camille lambert et osman
bandar d cela fait déjà deux semaines
qu'à l'atelier roydor on se prépare pour
la traditionnelle galette des rois
ils font des aisselles réajuster des
recettes
le but offrir une galette de qualité
pour les clients après les fêtes de fin
d'année on ne connaît bien cette période
on est rapide donc on sait faire on
s'adapte on s'organise pour pouvoir
faire des choses en temps et en heure et
ça se passe bien les gens et sa vessie
pourquoi ils viennent parce que parce
qu'on a
on n'utilise que des produits de qualité
qu'on a des maîtres pâtissiers qui ont
une grande expérience dans ce domaine et
que le résultat final il est il et il
est incomparable
la boulangerie roydor confectionne
cinghalais tous les jours pour
satisfaire la clientèle une clientèle
pour qui la galette des rois tient une
place importante est le maître mot est
la qualité avant tout par rapport à
l'histoire et aux
aux origines de cette de cette fête des
rois mages
je trouve que c'est très agréable de se
réunir autour d'une bonne galette des
rois en groupe sur le plan aussi bien
professionnel qu'en famille
voilà la période de la galette des rois
représente 10% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel de la boulangerie roydor c'est la
fin de cette édition du journal nouveau
rendez vous lundi aux horaires habituels
18 heures pour la première diffusion en
direct demain vendredi vous avez rendez
vous avec nicolas kirillovitch comme
chaque semaine pour à la reprise en ce
mois de janvier est de l hebdo tous les
reportages sont à voir en replay dès à
présent sur notre site internet et puis
sur l'application mobile tv fil 78 qui
est disponible sur l app store et sur
google play est très bonne soirée
[Musique]